[Music]
6 25 on your wednesday morning
you want something that's going to drive
you crazy how about permanently closing
some streets in downtown las vegas now
if you never drive anything other than
las vegas boulevard through the downtown
area that proposed closer that might not
mean a whole lot but
the nevada department of transportation
is doing everything it can to reach out
to those who
are going to be impacted it's all part
of the project that we've talked about
for sure
and we're going to keep talking about
that's upgrading the 95 515 east of the
spaghetti bowl
but which streets are we talking about
ndot director christina swano told a
windy news briefing on monday
7th 8th 10th
14th 15th 16th
19th and 21st we know that they will
create detours and it will impact the
community so we are
actively seeking feedback from anyone
who might be impacted by these closures
we're in phase one of the closures runs
till the 28th vehicle traffic is still
allowed but in phase two
from the 29th through april 12th there
will be full closures
only pedestrians and bicycles allowed so
to chime in
which ndot really wants you to do visit
the website n.dap.com we have that link
on our website 8newsnow.com it goes into
great detail about all the changes to
the 95 515 hope you check it out
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic
now dot com